لذا أه نريد الحصول على بعض
أسئلة المشاهدين لأن لديهم الكثير
عن اللقاح ، لذا إليك سؤال من
نونا
في ولاية واشنطن أه هذا
لقاح لمرة واحدة أم
سنحتاج إلى الحصول عليه كل عام مثل
لقاح الأنفلونزا
لذا مع الاحترام  إلى شركة um
pfizer ولقاحات Moderna ، هاتان
جرعتان ، لذا فهذه في الواقع طلقتان
في المقدمة مباشرة
بعد ذلك ، وما زلنا غير متأكدين من المدة التي
تستغرقها المناعة من اللقاح ،
ونأمل أن تكون على الأقل بضع سنوات
من المهم أن نفهم  أن
الفيروس التاجي وفيروس الأنفلونزا لهما
بيولوجيا مختلفة تمامًا ، فإن فيروس الإنفلونزا
يتحور في الواقع قليلاً
من عام إلى آخر ، وهذا هو السبب في أننا نحتاج إلى لقاح
سنوي للإنفلونزا ،
وهذا ليس هو الحال مع فيروس كورونا
، وبالتالي
فإن الحاجة إلى تكرار التطعيم بعد
هذين الأوليين
جرعات كوفيد تعتمد حقًا على
جهاز المناعة لدينا
وليس على الفيروس.
أعطيها
لأشخاص آخرين بعبارة أخرى ،
قد لا تظهر عليك الأعراض ولكن هل يمكن أن تكون
معديًا ،
لذلك هذا سؤال مهم حقًا
لا يمكنني التأكيد عليه
بما فيه الكفاية أننا لا نعرف الإجابة على
ذلك الآن
حتى نعلم أن اللقاح يمكن  منع
المرض لا
نعلم أنه يمكن أن يمنع أه العدوى
تمامًا
وبالتالي لا نعرف ما إذا كان
سيمنع انتقال العدوى ، وبالتالي فإن هذا
المفهوم
الكامل للقاح والأوساخ التي يسببها
مناعة القطيع يعتمد إلى حد كبير على
ما إذا كان اللقاح يمكن أن يمنع
انتقال العدوى فماذا عليك  سوف نستمع إلى
أشخاص مثلي ومسؤولين آخرين في
الصحة العامة يقولون انظروا ،
حتى لو تم تطعيمكم الآن ،
ما زلتم بحاجة
للامتثال لقيود الصحة العامة ،
بما في ذلك على وجه الخصوص ارتداء قناع ، من
المثير للاهتمام أن الأسئلة نفسها
هي دكتور غادجر  مثير جدًا للاهتمام لأنني
أعتقد أنه يُظهر أن الناس كانوا يولون
اهتمامًا وثيقًا حقًا
لأنهم يركزون على القضايا الحاسمة
ويأتي هذا السؤال من
om california ، هل من الآمن
أخذ التطعيم إذا كنت مصابًا بالفعل
بعدوى covid19 ،
قل في سبتمبر إذا كنت قد تلقيت
اللقاح ،
فهذا سؤال رائع آخر وكان
هناك بعض الجدل حول
ما إذا كان الأشخاص الذين أصيبوا به  يجب أن يتم تطعيم كوفيد ،
لذا تذكر أن معظم الأشخاص الذين
أصيبوا بالطمع قد أصيبوا
بعدوى خفيفة أو عديمة الأعراض ، لذا فأنت تعرف
أعراضًا قليلة أو معدومة حتى لا
يدركوا أنهم أصيبوا به
وبصراحة الخدمات اللوجستية لمحاولة
اكتشاف من كلهم
إذا كان عليك أن تقرر من يجب أن يتم
تطعيمه ، فسيؤدي
ذلك إلى جعل
المشكلة الضخمة بالفعل أكثر صعوبة ، لذا من
منظور السلامة ، من
الآمن تمامًا أن تحصل على
التطعيم حتى لو كنت مصابًا بالفيروس
وبصراحة أعتقد أنها فكرة جيدة
لأننا لا نعرف إلى متى تستمر هذه
المناعة الطبيعية على أي حال